Speaker 1: Some of you aren't going to believe
this.
Some of you are.
And I don't know which is more troubling that
we would still doubt the absurdity of the
stop the steel movement or that any new initiative
seems like something they would plausibly
do.
But let's talk about what is happening.
Republicans and according to Rudy Giuliani,
Donald Trump is also interested in this and
following it.
Republicans in Arizona who control the state
Senate are now ordering an audit of the state's
mail in ballots from the November 20 20 election.
That twenty twenty election, yes, of course,
the election was now almost a full six months
ago and yes, of course, even if somehow six
months later, Arizona was taken from Joe Biden
and given to Donald Trump, Joe Biden still
wins.
Joe Biden doesn't need the state of Arizona.
And yes, of course, the Arizona results have
already undergone multiple reviews that found
no evidence of fraud and they've been certified
and Joe Biden has been sworn in.
So this would do nothing, but they are still
pushing this.
And here is Rudy Giuliani appearing on former
Trump strategist Steve Bannon's program to
explain it.
Rudy is very interested in this audit and
Rudy is claiming that Donald Trump is very
interested in it as well.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I know you're pressed for time
and we are here to I got to ask you one thing
before you go.
By the way, just historically, is the president
the president has been briefed on this.
Is he up to speed on the details?
The president knew about this starting.
You know, this has been going on, this action,
of course, been going on now for about three
weeks, so he's been he's been up to date and
very interested in the whole thing.
And and even before the decision yesterday
when I saw him, he was he was quiet.
He's pretty sure it was going to happen.
I mean, they already lost this case two weeks
ago.
So this is a last gasp effort to almost re
argue the case.
They are they've lost about 10 days ago and
taken about 10 days to get everything together.
And Boris is absolutely correct.
They could have brought this thing any time
along the way.
So they waited until the last moment and then
they went into court and they're making many
of the same arguments they made before.
Speaker 1: So there it is, another humiliating
Republican attempt to like to do what, even
since again, overturning Arizona, which will
never happen.
But if it did somehow happen six months out,
it would not overturn the election results.
Now, here is a serious question.
How long do you think they will be pushing
this type of thing?
We know how long they'll continue claiming
the twenty 20 election was stolen.
The answer is a long time, probably forever.
Remember that Donald Trump still hasn't accepted
that he lost the popular vote in twenty sixteen.
He won that election electorally and he still
doesn't accept the popular vote results.
These people will never accept the 20 20 election
results.
But the real question is, how long will they
continue pushing stuff like this?
We're going to audit the mail in ballots.
What the real questions for me are questions
like how has Judy, Rudy Giuliani not been
disbarred by now?
Why does Steve Bannon continue to have Rudy
on to peddle this stuff?
Is it that good for traffic, for clicks?
Is this entire thing an opportunity for someone
to keep trying to make money from monetizing
gullible people who think that this garbage
might lead to something or go somewhere?
Like, is it is it a money grift in that sense?
It's almost remarkable how they always act
like this time we've got the motherlode and
every single time it's a dud.
Remember when they put all their eggs in the
basket of that wacky witness from Michigan,
Melissa Carone, who knew nothing about anything,
but she was going to blow this thing wide
open and she just made a fool out of herself
and Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump.
Here's a reminder of that, by the way.
At one point, this was the big shot they were
taking to overturn the results
Speaker 3: of the poll.
But the poll book is completely off, completely
off that I'd say that poll book is off by
over a hundred thousand, that pullback.
Why don't you look at the registered voters
on there?
How many registered voters are on their.
Did you do you even know the answer to that?
No, I guess I'm trying to get to the zero
zero zero.
So my question then is if that's how many
wait.
What about what about what about the out.
Right.
One hundred and twenty percent.
Speaker 2: Let's let's let Representative
Johnson ask his questions.
So the poll book.
No, there's two things that could happen here.
Either the poll book number if bounce from
multiple times, there's two options.
Option number one is that the poll book numbers
are not going to match.
They don't the actual not by thousands and
thousands of votes that we see right now.
Speaker 3: You take them off again.
Speaker 1: That one really made an impression
on me about the poor judgment that Rudy Giuliani
has, about what counts as a good witness in
these situations.
So I don't know.
I mean, like maybe I'll follow up on this
Arizona mail in ballot audit if people want
me to, or maybe I won't because it's worthless
trash that's not actually going anywhere.
What do you think is behind it?
Is someone making money from this in some
way?
I mean, listen, there's always a lawyer making
money somewhere on this type of thing when
you're making court filings and making motions
and filing paperwork.
So, yeah, there's probably lawyers making
money, but I don't think that that would really
be the motivation.
It seems that either it's being monetized
for donations in some way.
Somebody thinks that they're going to be pleasing
Trump by doing it and maybe that will lead
to something.
It's not really clear, but I'd be curious
to hear what you think is the driving force
behind this.
We're going to take a quick break.
We will go over some of the new pseudo scandals
from the weekend and much more.